we are so excited to share this with you
our major Tom Hanks exclusive now before
Tom became the world's most famous Koba
19 survivor he tackled one of the most
ambitious movies of his legendary career
we had enemy contact there in zero 8 7
no one has any idea if they are going to
make
what you did yesterday got us to today
it's not enough charlie not nearly
enough you want to find out something
grander about the human condition so
that you're a part of something that is
just bigger than yourself that to me is
the great power of cinema Tom who plays
a Navy captain in Greyhound says he sees
a similarity between the world war two
story and the pandemic we're living
through quote no one has anything other
than a best educated guess of when the
world is going to be through with this
all we can really do is our part the
same way as all those guys on board and
hope for some combination of Providence
and serendipity Tom and his wife Rita
stunned the world when they were
diagnosed with kovat 19 in Australia in
March Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson are
being cared in one of our world-class
hospitals in Queensland and he just made
this plea wear a mask social distance
wash your hands I have been the
celebrity canary in the coal mine for
the coronavirus how is quarantine life
you know it is what it is and in some
ways it's been a very creative time and
it's also been a very reflective time
Tom who's known as the nicest guy in
Hollywood has been spending his post
recovery time just how you might expect
he and Rita donated their plasma to help
in the fight against coronavirus in
April they celebrated their 32nd wedding
anniversary making a lovely dinner from
home and when this Australian boy was
bullied because his name is corona Tom
sent him a typewritten letter of
encouragement along with the corona
brand typewriter he wrote it on Tom also
hosted SNL stay safe we are in this for
the duration
in Greyhound out next Friday on appletv
plus Tom plays a first-time captain
crossing the Atlantic he also wrote the
script just imagine anyway a sheep would
try to escape a pack of wolves and
you've got a ship trying to get away
from the Nazi submarines that was the
game of the Battle of the Atlantic it's
the kind of embattled commander role
Hanks loves just like the heroic captain
Sully the Army Ranger in Saving Private
Ryan and astronaut Jim Lovell in Apollo
13 I don't think there's any commander
that doesn't have this innate fear of
being wrong but that has to be conquered
so what's next for Tom I will be playing
if all goes according to plan Colonel
Tom Parker the 63 year old is plain
Elvis's manager production was just
getting underway in Australia when Tom
was diagnosed and the pandemic hit
officials say they want to resume
production as soon as it's safe
[Music]